you're new to PO and it is so exciting
you're picking up new tricks getting
down tons of awesome new vocab and
you're also wondering what exactly
should you be learning in these beginner
stages what are the skills you should
focus on learning as you're getting
acquainted with the prop well friend
I've got you
covered Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of Po spinning
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I am going to drill down for
you my top five beginner Poise skills
that you should be learning in your
first stages as a PO spinner but before
we dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk flow fests flow
toys pyroar light toys and Ultra poy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- business friend of the channel
Becca Becken thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission so let's be real here most of us
out there are teaching ourselves POI in
some way shape or form and that comes
with both positives and negatives the
good part is you're not stuck in any
rigid Dogma you're able to learn what
you learn when you want to learn it and
decide things that you might not want to
learn and by the same token it can get
kind of confusing it's hard to know what
exactly you should be trying to pick up
at different points points during your
journey so with that in mind I compiled
up a list of five of what I think are
the most important skills that beginners
should be learning within their first
couple years of spinning poi these are
skills and Concepts that I think are the
most universal for all different poy
tricks that you're going to be learning
down the road and more importantly they
are things that you can begin to learn
the moment you start picking up a set of
Po and real quickly before we start make
sure to subscribe to the channel to get
access to a whole bunch more awesome po
videos now without further Ado let's
dive in skill number one
POI
planes planes are one of maybe only two
POI skills that I would argue are
literally Universal for every single po
trick you will ever learn getting down a
basic grasp of planer orientations to
your body is going to be essential for
anything else you do in your poy Journey
you're going to want to get down your
wall plane your wheel plane and of
course your horizontal or floor plane
now technically speaking there are
basically an infinite number of possible
plane orientations out there but we tend
to focus on only the those that have the
greatest amount of contrast to each
other thus all the planes that come at
right angles to each other regardless of
what tricks or techniques you're getting
down early on in your PO Journey make
sure you're taking time to really
clarify each of these different planer
orientations around your body so you're
ready to use them whenever you need to
and of course you might be wondering
based upon the introduction to this
section what exactly the other concept
of PO is that I think is just as
fundamental as planes are and that would
be skill number two timing and direction
put simply if you are working with two
POI then you are working in a system
where you need to know timing and
direction there's no way around it
whether the PO or spinning in together
same AKA Earth or in together opposite
AKA air in Split Time same direction AKA
water or in Split time opposites AKA
fire getting a good feeling for the PO
spinning in both the same direction as
well as opposite directions is going to
be essential for any po tricks you learn
in the future just like plane
orientation there are technically an
infinite number of timings that the PO
can be operating in and there's no
shortage of information out there about
how to spin POI in both quarter time as
well as triplicate time but you are
going to need all of these fundamentals
and without understanding them both
quarter time and triplicate time are
going to be difficult to get down in
particular getting a good feeling for
the split timings when you're starting
out tends to be one of those big humps
for people to get over but once you get
this down it'll be a skill that lasts
with you for as long as you're flowing
okay so now that we've got the two most
essential skills down I'm going to guide
you through three more that I think are
just as important but may not at first
appear like it on the
surface skill number three plane
facing so this one is surprisingly hard
to describe given how important a
concept it is plane facing simply put is
when we change which side of the plane
our body happens to be on we're also
going to change what direction the POI
happens to be spinning relative to us by
default human beings kind of have this
impression that whenever we move our
frame of reference the things around us
should move with us so if I'm moving
around in a particular space and I'm
spinning poi forwards on my sides it
seems natural that the PO should keep on
spinning forwards regardless of where I
am facing it at any given time and yet
we tend to find that if we're going to
conserve angular momentum that is keep
the PO in plane we're also going to have
to get used to the idea that it's going
to shift Direction relative to us from
forward to reverse or forward back again
in wheel plane or from clockwise to
counterclockwise and back again in wall
plane so long story short you're going
to want to practice a lot of reels in
different timing and directions when you
get started but that's not the weirdest
thing we're going to get
into skill number four Tic
Tacs so Tic Tacs are actually really
closely related to plane facing from our
last section but they also have a lot of
other uses as well when I say Tic Tac
what I actually mean is that I'm bending
the POI back and forth across parallel
planes you can think of this as being
what happens in a TW beat or a thread
the needle or any number of different
plane bending moves that happen to exist
in the poy world and there are so many
poy tricks that are dependent on getting
this skill down everything from 3B
weaves to thread the needles and
windmills to more advanced stuff say
like inversions and even toids the
amount of tricks that use this is nuts
but it all starts with just learning how
to bend the PO plane back and forth
across your body whether it be in wheel
plane wall plane or a horizontal plane
this skill is going to be essential to
have your toolbox for the future all
right we've talked planes we talked
timing and Direction we've talked about
the weird things that happen in Planes
when they change their orientation
relative to your body and vice versa so
what could be left what is there that
beginners need to get down that I
haven't covered yet skill number five
zero
points simply put zero points include
any moment when you bring the momentum
of the PO down to zero that could be
stalls it could be pendulums it could be
Point isolations there's a variety of
different things that fit under this
umbrella but in order to do transitions
this is a skill you need to have for
beginners I now advise starting off just
with pendulums practicing getting the PO
to swing back and forth to at least the
level of your hand on either side and
then try doing a loop around the hand
going back and forth to either end this
way you'll begin to get a feel for how
to add and subtract energy to the poy
and get it to stop and switch Direction
in the process and the thing is zero
points are not just useful for doing
transitions although I must say that
they are a fundamental skill to have in
order to do those no zero points wind up
being useful in their own right for a
variety of different purposes like both
pendulums and stalls look pretty
beautiful in their own right I
definitely discovered more than a few
patterns that incorporated both in my
first couple years of spinning poi that
I just considered to be cool looking
tricks in and of their own rights they
didn't have to be transition tools so
there you go my picks for the five most
essential skills for beginner po
Spinners to work on and if you are
intrigued about learning these different
skills and specifically exercises to
help you get them down I've got you
covered because that is the topic of
this month's flow Circle the flow circle
is an exclusive lesson that's available
only to my supporters on patreon that
gets delivered straight to your inbox
this month the theme is exercises that
will help you get down these fundamental
po skills everything from drilling those
Tic Tacs and different planer
orientations to developing hand
Independence so you can perform a zero
point with one hand and not the other a
crucial skill for getting down
transitions sign up now over at
patreon.com Factor poy the first lesson
is already up what are your picks for
the most essential skills for beginner
po Spinners to get down let me know down
in the comments also be sure to like
share and subscribe to help other people
find the video and to help my channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
and particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much y'all
Rock and if you out there watching or
not currently a supporter but you'd like
to become one you can do that by heading
on over to patreon at patreon.com
drexfactor pooy and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards but better than that
you'll be supporting me in my mission to
bring po spinning and flow Arts to the
whole wide world so go check that out
please and thank you and if you'd like
to see my picks for the first 10 tricks
that I think all po spit ought to learn
I will include a link to that video down
in the description as well as up on
screen thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and Flo to day and I'll
see you with a new video real soon take
care now peace